Since its establishment
CC Intelligence Technology has been committed
to shaping an efficient, interconnected
and trusted commercial world, using technology
Hi, I’m Lei Xiaopei
head of the CamScanner development team
CC is a unicorn enterprise specialized in AI and big data
focusing on text recognition and interpretation
for robotic vision and commercial big data
Camscanner is one of our flagship products
With nearly 400 million users worldwide
it is one of the most downloaded text
and image management apps in the world
Camscanner turns smartphones and tablets into portable scanners
fax machines, and file libraries
Leveraging the tools and platforms provided by Google
CamScanner has achieved great success
I am Wu Zhongze
a development engineer at CamScanner
We started adapting to Android 9 very early
We removed the network library
used by some 3rd party SDKs to reference Apache
tested and adapted the latest power management capability
and the limits for non-SDK interfaces
as well as adapted the common limits of the app
for back-end services and the authorization request
for front-end services
We have fully adopted functions
that create a better customer experience
such as notification enhancement and notch-in screen form factors.
Android Jetpack provides developers like us
with rich development components
and improves our development efficiency
The “permissions” component of Jetpack adapts
well to the authorization configuration for various smartphone brands
thus we avoid having to make specific adaptations
I’m Bu Lingzhuang
a development engineer at CamScanner
Our intention is to develop a versatile
easy-to-use, and efficient app
so versatility is a constant focus for us
Google supports soft-decoding of HEIF static images
in Android O MR1 and in the latest Android Pie
This capability is upgraded to support soft-encoding
and decoding of HEIF
HEIF as a new format is in many ways superior to older formats
advantages include smaller storage space requirement
dynamic image support, and transparency support
We have updated the app
to support importing HEIF format images
and the user experience so far has been positive
We also plan to add export capability into version 9.0
in future scheduled app updates
to fully leverage the new features in the latest operating system
and create more appealing systems
and software experience environments
We envision a future in which we can be the smartest
and most credible commercial platform in the world
Driven by new technologies from Google
we expect to provide more efficient and intelligent user experiences
while creating value for our customers
and driving exponential business growth
with our unrelenting commitment